fungi and slime molds
raced to decompose dead matter on the
forest floor
many spread by releasing spools
up to 30 000 a second
if just one of these spools lands in the
right place
and takes root it can colonize a whole
new
area
but not all fungi feed on the dead
[Music]
days ago a spool landed on this ant
now she's acting strange
a network of roots has infiltrated her
muscles
her body has been taken over by
cordyceps
a parasitic fungus
it floods her brain with chemicals
drugging her
compelling her to head where conditions
are perfect
[Music]
just the right amount of light just the
right amount of humidity
for the parasite growing inside
[Music]
it forces her to clamp down in a death
bite
and cordyceps reveals its gruesome
nature
[Music]
[Music]
after three weeks of growth
cordyceps can release its own spores
infecting more ants releasing more
spores
infecting more acts releasing
more spores infecting more axis
infecting more and more and more
cordyceps can wipe out entire ant
colonies
but more than just ants are at risk
there are over 600 species of cordyceps
spread across the world
most are found in jungles
where they prey on a whole host of
victims
[Music]
you